YURI GRINSHTEYN:
The ancient Greeks
told of how Prometheus
stole fire from the gods
and brought it to humankind.
Today, Prometheus is
bringing better observability
to Kubernetes operators as a
leading open source monitoring
framework.
In this episode, we'll look at
how to set up Prometheus on GKE
and use it to instrument
your application with custom
metrics.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Last time, we looked at how to
use OpenCensus to add custom
metrics to our application.
Today, we'll do the
same with Prometheus.
Before we start, a
bit of background.
Prometheus is an open source
systems monitoring and alerting
tool kit originally
built at SoundCloud.
It has a very active
developer and user community
and joined the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation in 2016.
So how do you set it up?
The fastest and easiest
way to actually set up
Prometheus in your
GKE cluster is
to use Helm, which is a
package manager for Kubernetes.
Once you have Helm
installed and configured,
you can install
Prometheus in your cluster
simply by running
the helm install
stable/prometheus command.
The install will create
multiple components--
the Prometheus server itself, an
exporter running on every node
to capture node
statistics, alert manager
to send email notifications,
and the push gateway
to accept metrics to be
pushed to Prometheus.
We'll primarily interact
with the server.
Let's validate the installation
by port forwarding the server
pod to our local host.
This allows us to access
the Prometheus UI and graph
metrics to confirm that data
collection and persistence are
working.
Now that Prometheus
is installed,
we are ready to start adding
metric instrumentation
to our application.
But first, let's quickly
review the kinds of metrics
that Prometheus supports.
A counter is a
cumulative metric that
represents a single increasing
value that can only increase
or be reset to 0 and restart.
For example, you
can use a counter
to represent the number
of requests served, tasks
completed, or errors.
A gauge is a metric
that represents
a single numerical value that
can arbitrarily go up and down.
Gauges are typically
used for measured values,
like temperatures or
current memory usage,
but also counts, like the
number of concurrent requests.
A histogram samples
observations and counts them
in configurable buckets.
It also provides a sum
of all observed values.
Histograms are most
often used to measure
the distributions of things like
request durations or response
sizes.
Finally, a summary samples
observations and provides
a total count and a sum
of all observed values.
It also calculates
configurable quantiles
over a sliding time window.
Summaries are usually used to
values where the total value is
important, like payload sizes.
Now that we know
what kind of metrics
we can expose in
our application,
it's important to understand
how Prometheus itself works.
It's a basic pull model.
Our application needs to expose
a dedicated endpoint where
the metrics will be
available, and we
need to tell Prometheus
where that endpoint is
and how frequently to
scrape it for metrics,
so let's do both of those now.
First, let's instrument
our application.
We'll create a
simple Go application
and expose a gauge metric in it.
Here's the code.
You can find a link to the
repo in the video description.
The first step is to define
the metric itself as a gauge
and provide its name
and a description.
Next, we create a
function that will
set the value of our metric.
In our example, we're just
generating a random value
so that we know it'll
change every time.
Now we can run our application.
When we access the
metrics endpoint,
we can see that our custom
metric is generated and shown
here.
Now our application
is instrumented
with a custom metric, which is
being exported to Prometheus.
We need to tell Prometheus
where to find this information.
We'll do that by adding some
annotations in the deployment
spec in our application before
we deploy it to Kubernetes.
We'll enable scraping
and define the port
and endpoint where the
metrics are available.
Our last step is to set up
Stackdriver integration,
to have this metric be
ingested into Stackdriver.
We'll install the
Stackdriver collector
on our cluster, which will
patch the Prometheus server
deployment.
Now when we go to
Metrics Explorer,
we can see our random
value metric there.
I hope that you've seen how
Prometheus is a fantastic way
to add custom metric
instrumentation
to your application and have
those metrics be ingested
in Stackdriver.
Thank you for joining
me today, and come back
next time when we explore
options for managing monitoring
and logging costs.
That's it for this episode.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]